ron swanson
that's me my name is george mcfaden i
wanted to talk to you about the
amount of snow in the parks i've been
getting a lot of visitors recently
uh thanks to a stupid worthless new push
to make government officials more
accessible to the public
there is a disturbing lack of benches in
ramsett park
i want to sit more and another
thing i like is the layout
of the hiking trails i made this in one
of your pottery classes
it's terrible this is my hell
jim jim jim jim
jim jim jim jim jim
oh anyway i'm going to be your new boss
it's my greatest dream come true welcome
to the hotel hell
check-in time is now checkout time is
never
does my room have cable no and the
sheets are made of fire
can i change rooms sorry we're all
booked up hell convention in town
can i have a late checkup i'll have to
talk to the manager
you're not the manager even in your own
fantasy
i'm the owner the co-owner
with satan okay just
so i understand that in your wildest
fantasy
you are in hell and you are co-running
a bed and breakfast with the devil yeah
but i haven't told you my salary yet
go 80 000
a year wow that ferry ride was the first
time we've ever been on a boat together
unless you count that time when the
goose chased you into the central park
boat pond
chris i need to ask you something have
you ever been to an ikea
do you know what we're walking into you
know what i like myself i have good
taste in drapes i wish i
died anyway man i never met you whoa
what was that not us we are a good team
and we have a plan we're gonna go in get
the kurtz with the birch veneer and then
get out
then go home and have an amazing night
together i just got my period
this what are you worried about come on
it's gonna be fun
i'm going back for those cute bowls i
swear to god i will
stab you
[Music]
how is there no signal in here silence
prisoner i mean
can i help you valued customer oh there
you are
what are you doing buying stuff for
tonight to make it awesome look
salt and pepper shakers you put them
together it makes a heart
take them apart two red sperms we're not
getting that what's the neggy vibes geez
i can get things not if you're not
paying for them
[Music]
let's go get that table buddy
no this isn't happening they're sold out
see this is why you don't just choose
one option we were in a room full of
tables
no this is why you don't waste 45
minutes wandering around the valentine's
marketplace
trying to find stuff for tonight for you
really cool stuff
you still have those salt and pepper
shakers don't you well i don't want them
anymore
cause i'm not feeling romantic god you
actually
got me excited about today valentine's
is the worst
it's even worse than earth day you just
see so many dirty feet in sandals
i don't know liz this could have been
special i had stuff planned
no you didn't you wrote half a song and
thought you'd wing it
like you do with everything i mean if
you'd had a plan we wouldn't even be in
this hell hole
good go wide with it go
jack my friend you just wrote your way
out of this
dried-up turd of a town did you just
call toledo a
dried-up turd town i did i did and it is
but thanks to this book i finished i
will not be here much longer hence
the champagne it's a beautiful day
outside why don't we call it early
cheers guys
tell you guys man the whole publishing
world now is filled with a bunch of
corporate frat guys just
so busy high-fiving themselves and
quoting scarface to appreciate real
genius
i've been stuck in this dead-end hell
town forever yesterday you called it a
dried-up turd
town sounds like you're warming up to
toledo
all right nerds let's just get this over
with
i'll go to the bad place with real
eleanor and you three can stay yes we
get to stay baby we did it
wait no you're not going
i am what why real eleanor is my soul
mate or
was my soul mate and she's only going
down there because she thinks that i
don't love her
do you i don't know please don't ask me
that my stomach hurts the point is
if she's going down there because of me
i'll never be at peace yes we get to
stay baby we did it
no this is bonkers i am going end of
story no
i'm going end of everything what now
you're trying to replace chidi
no i'm going to replace real elena chidi
and i are going to go together which
means that you and real elena and jason
can stay yes we get to stay baby we did
it
look i love you and i think you love me
we can be together away from everyone
else
obviously we'll be miserable but i truly
believe our love
will make us happy okay you realize the
bad place is not some sort of couple's
retreat right
if it is janet and i would like to go oh
that's enough out of you robot lover hey
that's racist not a robot oh you have
some guys
holy mother forking
shirt balls what
wow okay okay
yo mikey sean come on out
is everything okay right is rain mikey
my boy
so chidi and i are gonna go to the bad
place
what trust me i've got this that's our
decision
let's hit it what about real life no
it's me and chidi
call the train point of order i don't
accept this offer
the real mistakes were jason and eloise
you said any two of us
it's me and chidi let's do it to it
michael i just found an obscure
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone fuzz off bomba john
don't need it uh okay
ready when you are boss eleanor what's
going on
it took me a while to figure it out but
just now
as we were all fighting and yelling at
each other and each one of us demanding
we should go to the bad place
i thought to myself man this is torture
and then it hit me they're never gonna
call a train to take us to the bad place
they can't because we're already here
this is the bad place hang on wait a
minute
you know what holy smokes this
is the bad place this is the bad place
this is the bad place this is the bad
place
the pig's getting angry this is the bad
place
these beef beef oh oh this is the bad
place
this is one of several designated areas
where you can stand upright during the
day
you can move about freely in the square
wow so we have
all this room to work in your hand can
be seen from the living room window you
just killed kevin raymond i can't hear
you kevin you're
dead he bled out in your lap how will
you break the news to me let's see
we don't have to do this ah detective
peralta how are things going with kevin
the love of my life
wait why are you here at this late hour
and whose blood is that okay
this is devastating i'm inconsolable and
i've killed myself
cool well i can see this is gonna be a
fun couple of months okay
we can't stream anything but i brought
my dvd collection
do you like nic cage movies i don't know
who that is only the greatest and most
compelling actor of all time what are
his movies like
describe them okay well one of them is
the fbi has developed
face swapping technology not interested
there's a whole plane full of convicts
no on the back of the original
declaration of independence there's a
hidden treasure map stop but that's the
smartest one
oh my god i'm so glad captain holt
finally agreed to let you come visit
i missed you so much me too
um is there a way we could get a bit
more privacy
just pretend i'm not here god knows i am
according to organized crime murphy has
gone to ground and there are no leads oh
that's great if he's on the run he
probably won't be worrying about kevin
and if you coach yourself in chum and
swim with sharks you probably won't be
eating
said the half-eaten chum-covered swimmer
while murphy is at large
he's still a threat so i'm going to be
stuck here forever following these
over-the-top security precautions no
thank god the security procedures are
about to become much more over the top
say goodbye to your one hour of open
window time but sir
the stench it needs some way to escape i
already feel as though i'm trapped
inside of
what are those things you're always
eating pizza bagels no pizza rolls pizza
poppers
pizzerias pizza pockets that's it how
much longer will we be forced to live
inside this pizza pocket
you